I couldn't I just couldn't get it out
because I don't yeah but I can imagine
no I know that's what I'm trying to
because it sounds like all wonderful but
we're just I just want to show you
reality right it's not wonderful yeah I
don't think it's wonderful at all you've
got one baby in one hand you're trying
to stir something now but I understand
that wonderful he's wonderful like it's
wonderful but at the same time like I'm
not saying it's gonna be in this easy
smooth ride and I'm just gonna be like
no obviously they're all you are going
to go through your own internal
struggles and battled and Mentor as well
well I'm just saying nobody cares about
that when you're alive and a mother I'm
I'm just saying that I don't mind I